[Music]
you don't have to be nervous i i'm not
nervous
well they're all so impressive you're
impressive they're going to be obsessed
with you
[Music]
they're not as nihilistic as they look
on the internet you guys this is me oh
whoa
this is your first relationship oh no
you just kind of give that vibe
well you know that has weed in there
right
[Music]
who wants to play body spotty spotties
so how do you play
if you draw the piece of paper that has
the x on it you are the murderer let's
go
and if you're the murderer you have to
kill someone by touching them on the
back
the most important part if you come
across a body you have to yell
[Music]
our friend is dead
someone's doing this they're trying to
kill us off one by one that'll be so
obvious if i were the
killer for the neighbor
where are you
oh
[Applause]
i'm staying safe really because it looks
like you're grabbing a meat cleaver to
go look for my boyfriend
[Music]
is
i brought something what is it
it's zucchini bread
yum i'm a hot girl pop girl rich girl
i'm a girl fast girl catch me if you can
go
you